you know I am an outsider this book is
written from the perspective of someone
who was fairly psychedelically naive who
got interested and entered this
community there is a perspective though
that the newcomer has that no one else
ever has again I mean I learned this a
long time ago as a writer one of the
most influential books I read when I was
13 was a book called paper lion by
George Plimpton anybody know who that is
yeah okay so he was a he was also the
editor of The Paris Review and he
reinvented sports writing by instead of
just being on the sideline chomping on a
cigar he decided he was going to train
with the Detroit Lions and he persuaded
them to do it and actually play
quarterback in a scrimmage game in
during spring training summer training
and that gave him a perspective that not
only the sideline sports writers had
never had but the players had never had
because they took it for granted they've
been playing football their whole life
they were used to getting their heads
bashed in you know that was normal I
don't mean to liken any of you two to
you know football players getting their
heads bashed in but but the fact is
there's something about first sight
first experience that opens up something
that you never recapture again so I
think that my my newness to the
experience contribute something and and
it certainly allowed me to write about
it yes in a way that is hard to do if
you have a lot of experience and then
there is the fact that I come you know
that most books about psychedelics and I
don't say this to criticize them have
been written from within the community
and I have to tell you to people outside
the community those books like might be
written in another language yes they're
like they're Greek to a lot of people
and that so my my reluctance the fact
that I had so many so much resistance I
had to overcome I mean fear of the drugs
distaste for the music reluctance about
the New Age lingo I mean there were so
many things I had to get over that I
think that creates a perspective that
that or becomes a door for people in the
mainstream to take a look at this world
so to me I think that's the value added
of having you know someone is not an
expert and also as a writer I don't like
writing as an expert one of the reasons
I left food is I'd become an expert and
it's much less it's much more fun to
write at the beginning of the learning
curve and let your readers learn with
you yes and bring them on the journey
instead of completing the journey and
then standing up and lecturing them and
that's all that's a whole other way to
write and it's not what I do I totally
agree with that and I want to add to
that as well you spent what four years
researching this book yeah talking to
researchers around the world taking
psych adults yourself that's nothing to
you know scoff at here you spent four
years researching them you know it's
it's true yeah I still don't think I'm
an expert I mean I still have a lot to
learn but also you know even those
people in the communities some of them
some of them know about the history some
of them don't some of them know about
the neuroscience some of them don't so I
think that even for people in the
community there's material that may be
unfamiliar yeah well you don't have the
depth of these experts but a breadth of
knowledge yeah I think there's value in
that generally yeah I also bring the
perspective of someone who's worked on
plants for a very long time and has been
interested in nature and I put this in
the context I mean if people people who
wonder how I got from food to
psychedelics well they're both about
nature they're things we take into our
body that change us we change them and
in the process and it's part of our
engagement with the natural world which
is fundamentally my topic as a writer
food is one branch on that tree
psychedelics and and psychoactive drugs
in particular or not